[Música]
bueno un placer estar acá la verdad es
que es un honor abrir el evento y bueno
desde verdad no es la primera edición
como lo hicieron mi nombre es douglas yo
soy el responsable por el área de
marketing de una empresa que hace que
hacemos vía pública y lo bueno de mi
trabajo no la jota se dejó y estamos en
cuatro mil ciudades y nos toca estar
vivirla esta ciudad no me toca vivir en
cada una de esas paso por esto hoy es mi
cuarto país en esta semana estoy ahí
haciendo una gira y me encanta la ciudad
yo soy de origen de brasil
me tocó vivir a ella en un grado escena
de ciudad de centro al lado de cada una
de ellas me llevo algo de buenos aires
ustedes ya saben que me lleven a la
tonada si me matan en brasil cuando
hablo argentino me quiere matar allá
pero bien ahí estamos pero la verdad lo
que me gusta de la ciudad esto todo que
se puede hacer es donde vivimos nosotros
porque vivimos nosotros en grandes
aglomeraciones urbanas no ustedes en
ciudad méxico yo vivo en brasil ahora en
san pablo también es otra pero la ciudad
nos sigue desde el siempre desde el
inicio de la civilización el hombre ha
decidido vivir en una ciudad vivir en
conjunto en sociedad y qué implica esto
que es vivir en sociedad a ver si anda
el 'no sí que significa vivir en una
ciudad grande como como me como df como
como san pablo
es un mundo de contradicciones no la
ciudad las ciudades no se implican eso
hoy tenemos autos que llegan fácilmente
200 kilómetros por hora y seguimos a
paso
caminar es casi las personas pasan más
rápido que nosotros en nuestros autos en
la ciudad se puede ir
tenemos cuántos días son acá en méxico y
de vacaciones 15 o 30 días tiene ustedes
de vacaciones en general son como no sé
en promedio 15 a pasamos tenemos 15 días
de vacaciones estamos esperando las 15
días vacaciones y nos quedamos atrapados
en el tránsito como 45 días de nuestras
vidas todos los años paradas en el
tránsito esto es vivir en la ciudad
entonces es complicado no vivimos no se
puede hacer todos vivimos a prestados
pagamos carísimo
es un poco lo que nos toca vivir en la
ciudad pero porque entonces la gente va
a vivir en la ciudad y más allá de estos
los problemas que hay hay algo que es
vivimos cerca de gente muy distinta
están a nuestro lado gente totalmente
distinta a ver
es que pueden generar tanta gente un al
lado del otro cada uno que piensa
distinto del otro es la receta perfecta
para conflictos no y pasan muchos en
todas las grandes ciudades pasan muchos
conflictos conflictos desde el punto de
vista religioso ideológico para también
pasar conflictos cercanos de vecinos y
ese vecino que me se prende la música a
este volumen a esta hora de la noche no
porque estamos viviendo juntos gente
distintas que vive juntos pero también
la ciudad esta diversidad está esta
complejidad que hay en la ciudad es
también lo que nos permite disfrutar del
distinto porque si estás en una ciudad
puedes caminar un par de cuadras un par
de manzanas y si ya estás en otro lado
con gente que piensa distinto cruzas con
gente que mira dice y este de dónde
salió no y por qué está la ciudad es la
convivencia es tener gente
distintas viviendo juntos y esto es lo
que te permite esto me encanta perdón a
ver si vuelvo a 1 esto me encanta el
ejemplo este de jerusalén que para mí es
una ciudad que tiene todos los problemas
de conflictos de contradicciones en una
ciudad y aún haciendo de una de las
ciudades más creativas del mundo porque
yo creo que la creatividad viene
justamente de esto viene de la chispa
creativa que se genera desde el derroche
de gente distinta porque lo homogéneo
resulta en cosas homogéneas lo que está
solo lo mismo no va a ir a algo distinto
si tenés un grupo de personas que
piensan igual salen cosas iguales y está
ahí las redes sociales el laborismo de
facebook que todos nos dicen que nos
meten en burbujas y solo tenemos acceso
a la información y hill 10 igual a
nosotros en la ciudad es el opuesto a
eso es meter ahí en tu cara delante tuyo
que hay gente que piensa distinto que
hay gente que actúa distinto que a gente
que no vive distinta y esto la chispa
creativa pero si la ciudad tiene esto es
una contradicción tenemos gente distinta
que vive juntos tenemos creatividad pero
también tenemos conflicto ya nosotros en
mercadotecnia es lo que nos implica
tenemos que hablar con gente distinta
y hablo a
y vos escuchás a vos escuchás ve no se
escuchase porque está en lado a lado y
el mensaje al mismo pero la comprensión
la tiene cada uno
entonces como hablar con esta gente la
idea es el resto termina haciendo esto
bueno
y ahí estamos nosotros hoy nos volvimos
convertimos en nómadas nómadas urbanos
como los me gusta llamar a nosotros
mismos porque tenemos estamos todo el
tiempo moviéndonos nos llegamos a un
lado y ya pienso uy me toca salir muy
pronto yo llego a mi casa y ya tengo que
dormir y ya tengo que salir
puedo ir a cualquier lado de la ciudad
pero el tránsito me atrapa y trató de
solucionar mi vida cerca de mi casa o
cerca de mi trabajo es como una dualidad
y perdón
es una dualidad tremenda y él no es este
tipo que no solo
qué pasa todo el tiempo moviéndose
entonces tiene una limitación de tiempo
todo lo que una ciudad nos puede ofrecer
nos ofrece miles de oportunidades pero
tenemos tiempo para esto no no nos queda
tiempo entonces la ciudad es este gran
conflicto y nosotros aún creemos muchas
veces que vivimos en este momento en
estos tiempos allí llegue el papá del
trabajo los niños están ahí ya duchas
limpias
van a cenar y después mira la tele este
mundo si existió pero no pero ya no es
más así a la vida no nos toca más vivir
en este modelo tan perfecto así como de
sueños de que miramos en la tele
la vida no es más así offline o entonces
y tampoco es
transponer el offline hacia el online ya
que hay bastante gente joven quizás
ustedes no siquiera sepan lo que es esto
pero hace 15 años explotó second life
second life fue como una fiebre que la
gente está decía pero que que se puede
hacer eso es increíble puede ser
cualquier persona y desde ahí de tu
hogar porque en este momento estaba
accesando la internet desde tu casa
podría ser cualquier persona vivir a
donde quisiera había hay un mundo
virtual que hasta propiedad como casas
se compraban ahí
y yo en este momento de trabajador a
otra empresa invertían fiestas en el
club y la gente salía a bailar pero no
en el mundo virtual y los imaginaba y en
sus pijamas en su casa diciendo che que
viene esta esta fiesta no está bárbara
na crees que esto anduvo obvio que no la
gente no quiere vivir lo el el mundo
offline el mundo real una una versión
online del mundo real no obviamente yo
quiero salir yo quiero salir a conocer
gente pero de verdad no quiere estar
encerrado en mi habitación el mundo
virtual exclusivo no 12 boeing second
life es una tierra de zombies ya no hay
nadie es pero aún sigue viva si quieren
los que no las conocen si quieren
conocerlas le digo pueden ir
llegamos a este punto donde somos
digitales pero vivimos en un mundo real
y se habla mucho de transformación
digital y yo paro para pensar yo que
transformación es transformar es
agarrar lo que es offline y volverlo al
online
y digo nueces es entonces no estamos
viviendo una en una era de la
transformación digital pero es centre
era una era la era de la integrasa vital
la integración digital es si vivir
aprovechar sacar provecho de todo lo que
tiene el digital pero adentro de mi vida
es integrar el online con el offline
y es lo que hace la gente si lo miras
este es un típico ejemplo no caminamos
con nuestros celulares y los que logran
hacer esto logran hacer es un éxito
tremendo yo me acuerdo del pokemon gol
acá todo mundo yo creo que casi todos lo
conocen a pokemon gol fue un éxito
tremendo y quiere el pokemon gol en el
mundo real con el mundo virtual no con
los los pokemon esto que la gente salía
a cazar esto que fue una fiebre no sé no
sé si ustedes saben pero pokemon gol
cual se derrumbó la internet de todo el
mundo en un determinado momento el flujo
de datos en internet de pokemon gol
superó 52 veces lo que ellos se estimaba
a punto de que llegar a las oficinas de
anai antich la gente del gobierno de
eeuu diciendo chicos basta
la internet se va ron se va a caer todo
no vamos a tener internet por un par de
horas por una cuestión de pokemon pero
esta es la fiebre como la gente está
dispuesta a mezclar el virtual con el
real hay ejemplo de publicidad y yo
tenía un ejemplo acá para atraerlos es
una campaña genial que hicieron como
búsquedas sacando provecho que cada uno
de nosotros tiene uno de esos en
nuestros bolsillos y quienes logran
hacer esta unión de los dos es lo final
bueno pero por qué hablo esto
porque es muy fácil concentrarse en un
lado o en el otro lado la unión de los
dos es el gran reto que tenemos nosotros
vivimos tenemos la oportunidad de vivir
en ciudades enormes y así hay problemas
de vivir en ciudades no les voy a mentir
tenemos problemas pero tenemos que
también sacar esta negatividad de que
hay tantos problemas en la ciudad la
violencia el tránsito esto todo y
disfrutar de nuestra ciudad disfrutar de
la ciudad es ir a explorar la ciudad
como si fuéramos turistas no pero no
desde acá también hay no los buses doble
piso que están los turistas pobres
turistas que se suben a unos 32 buses no
son aburridísimos está en cualquier lado
del mundo están ahí los doble piso la
gente que habla así con una motivación
como si estuvieran ahí no no la gente
quiere vivir experiencias quiere vivir
como local entonces yo pienso que vienen
turistas a mi ciudad a vivir como en un
local y ustedes saben acá está el
ejemplo de ir bien
no experiencias que es no quieres
vivir como turista quieres vivir la
experiencia local en ciudad méxico yo ya
he probado un par de experiencias la
verdad me parecieran bárbaras otro día
salí en bici para comer tacos en la
calle estabas como así y me encantó
todos y como me sentí en mexicano ya
estaba no sé ahora estoy quiero probarlo
hablando de la lucha a ver si en esta
semana me toca me toca vivir pero es
esto y nosotros muchas veces tenemos
todo esto nuestro disponible nuestra
disponibilidad y vamos siempre a los
mismos lugares vamos siempre a donde lo
conocemos a dónde encontramos a gente
que ya conocemos que está bárbaro está
bueno ver a los amigos pero también está
bueno aprovechar sacar provecho de la
diversidad que hay en las ciudades
entonces mi invitación es que
que a ver que conozcamos que salgamos
porque la d
el mundo está ahí el mundo la ciudad
están en nuestra disposición cruzadas
con la gente habla con la gente y hay
gente que no pasa / en el subte en el
metro y yo soy siempre de los que hablan
con los conductores de uber con los de
taxi y les quiero escuchar porque no es
sólo hablar es escuchar escuchar la
actora escuchar cómo viven escuchar en
san pablo que es una ciudad también así
de grandes yo tenía miles de prejuicios
y ahí voy a barrios y trato de vivir
pasar un día en el barrio y miro como la
gente vive vivo como trabajan viven como
se relacionan y como esto cambia todo de
la forma porque si de verdad es muy
fácil
ya pensar tener una imagen predefinida
de cada barrio de cada gente pero lo
bueno es bueno es aprovechar este
conocer a esta gente porque si la vida
está el virtual está la oportunidad
están los amigos está en la universidad
si están se puede hacer miles de cosas
pero mi invitación final para terminar
la charla es que ustedes salgan salgan a
explorar la ciudad a vivir la ciudad a
conocer la ciudad porque así la vida la
vida es digital pero también la vida
pasa allá afuera chicos muchas gracias
gracias por todo
[Música]